[Music]
when i was living in france i got to
know two very distinct traditions of
french food on the one hand there was
the delicious oil cuisine i cooked all
day in the restaurant and on the other
hand there was the food you ate in
people's homes which is a lot simpler to
make but still absolutely delicious
my ultimate french-inspired lunch is
very light bright and really takes me
back to when i lived in paris
it's my take on the salad nicoise served
with a delicious ghost cheese and pear
tartine
think of the nicoise as an assembly job
of delicious ingredients brought
together with a fantastic dressing
the secret behind my
salad nicoise is in the dressing
spoon dijon mustard into a pestle and
mortar
some people top the salad with anchovies
and capers but in mine they're the base
to the dressing we're gonna grind that
to a paste
and then get the garlic in there season
well with black pepper
it doesn't need any salt in there
because of the
anchovies add a couple tablespoons of
red wine vinegar olive oil and lastly
flat leaf parsley to give the dressing
freshness against those deep flavors
it's a thick rich substantial dressing
dressing done now for the salad ball
potatoes green beans and eggs from a
rolling ball seven and a half to eight
minutes you should keep that nice
yolky creamy texture in the center once
the eggs are ready put them into cold
water to stop them cooking and this is a
great trick to peel them
so much easier peeling eggs when you use
the water
that they've been cooling down in and
the water will seep underneath all the
shell
so the
whole shell just gets peeled off with
one beautiful big layer
now
beans
nice and crunchy season the beans and
potatoes whilst they're still warm so
they absorb more flavor a little drizzle
of olive oil
salt pepper
and just
let them sit there
whilst the potatoes and beans cool down
i'm doing a simple french open sandwich
which is called a tartine
this is delicious
first i'm toasting baguette on the
griddle
lightly oil
your griddle pan
get your bread
stick it on there
take a pear
it goes brilliantly well with goat's
cheese
slice the pear into finger width pieces
that's the color we're looking for that
dark
crispy texture
now for the ghost cheese
give it a season
it doesn't need salt
because a little fresco cheese is
already
quite salty
then a handful of crumbled walnuts
they go under the grill whilst they put
the tuna nice ones together
my secret to assembling a great nicoise
salad is to start in the middle of the
plate and add ingredients layer by layer
there's one thing i'm always missing the
bottom of salad is dressing so i like to
put it on the plate first
baby gem lettuce is great because it's
robust and holds that heavy dressing
then add firm waxy salad potatoes and
green beans i like them to have a bit of
a crunch
canned tuna can be fantastic i'm using a
good quality one in olive oil which has
been drained
next baby plum tomatoes which have a
lovely intense sweet flavor and then
my eggs that nice
dark rich yolk
beautiful
[Music]
yogurt's still creamy
inside
he's a little olive nicoise this will
work just as well with other black
olives and then you're dressing
drizzle that round gently beautiful
that is a nicoise
in heaven
now tartine
wow
just a smell
of those grilled walnuts
that is beautiful
a simple but very elegant
tuna nicoise
but delicious
goat's cheese sandwich
wonderful
[Music]
my vibrant and gutsy nisswa salad with
that incredible anchovy and caper
dressing served with a pear and goat's
cheese tartine too good to let the
french keep all to themselves
[Music]
a stunning prawn and cucumber salad with
a spicy yogurt dressing
a simply delicious anchovy dip
and a sticky chocolate fridge cake that
won't fail to revive a flag in family
until he's keen to get in on the action
[Music]
what are your favorites a marshmallow
and peanut fridge cake
perfect for
a picnic first things first you have to
slowly melt the chocolate
that's bad that's good
i'm gonna break up the chocolate
right in there next butter goes in
couple tablespoons of golden syrup
it's so good
if we melt chocolate too quickly it
starts to separate and destroy
the best and safest way to melt
chocolate is always use a bain-marie but
i'm going to keep a really close eye on
mine and heat it over a super low heat
this stunning little cake has your
favorites in there our digestives now
put your hands in there and give them
like that one at a time ago
and crush what's the one thing that you
love about a picnic
i love eating outside especially on a
nice summery day
not so much in the winter no
that's going to be the crunchy part of
our fridge cake
and it's called a fridge cake because it
can sit in the fridge or you can freeze
it now the peanuts in please
can you use it without peanuts if you're
allergic to peanuts oh you can do yeah
definitely no
what are these little babies cranberries
cranberries
from there
marshmallows my favorite okay
they're so bright aren't they why do you
love marshmallows so much because
they're so squishy all right give that a
nice mix up
chocolate is melting nicely okay i want
you to pour that in and i'll mix it nice
and gently slowly slowly slowly soon
nice
now
touch more please
good isn't it good give that a little
mix with daddy please look they're all
melty and nice and cool and gooey now
we're going to line the tray
so this is quite easy to make because um
you don't have to bake it
you just set it yeah i want you to start
pushing it into the corners please with
your fingers just laying out nice and
flat
ah it's all nice and marshmallow and
oozy
to get the spatula okay and look
how delicious does that look
really delicious i can eat it right now
i couldn't because it's not set
so when that sets okay
it'll go nice and firm and then we can
cut it into little bars little squares
triangles triangles
[Music]
good
but the important part of pushing it
down is that we can slice it
and the more we push the thinner we can
slice
okay good good
[Music]
fridge cake done
now i'm gonna make the most amazing
anchovy dip with vegetables and bread
first cut slices of baguette and bake in
the oven at 180 degrees c for six
minutes or until crisp
meanwhile roughly chop garlic and
shallots and add to a food processor
along with a tin of good quality
anchovies
sprinkle in some pitted black olives
flat leaf parsley and drizzle in the
reserved anchovy oil and a little olive
oil
blitz to a paste and add pepper
then decant into a jar ready to
transport
serve with a handful of fresh baby
carrots
peppery radishes and your crisp baguette
toast
anchovy dip a portable and deliciously
palatable alfresco treat
[Music]
now a spicy chili yogurt dressing with a
prawn salad first things first i'd like
you to make the dressing
fish
doesn't sauce smell like fishes so one
and a half tablespoons of fish sauce
two chilli
i like this especially if you have it on
the side of the pork
little teaspoon of sugar
oh that's it good in
so four tablespoons of yogurt
three
four
some zest in there
why are you making it in a jam jar not a
bowl well this is for a little picnic
and it's a great way of transporting
we squeeze the lime in there and then we
put the lid on shake it
and then i want you to shut it on tight
[Music]
come on it's a bit like a tummy
see
that sounds like my tummy
only sometimes only sometimes thank you
for that
hi nick is you
and the first time you have it's like a
little thingy it's fresh
salty citrusy
but delicious now cucumber and the salad
i want to get rid of all the seeds so if
you just nice and gently
peel
the cucumber why do you feel it can you
not eat the skin on it you can eat the
skin but i want this salad to taste
light
and fresh you can use a knife for this
too though can't you you can peel with a
knife but a speed peeler takes off the
slices nice and thinly so much quicker
so much quicker that's why it's called a
speed peeler
looks better now looks a bit naked it
does look a bit naked doesn't it
now you get your spoon
and see
what happens
a teaspoon just takes out all those
seeds
so whilst it sits in the dish
it doesn't make the salad go all soft
because that cucumber is nice and
crunchy
[Music]
that's really good
there you go so see where your knuckles
are there
that's what's always going to protect if
you put that little finger out
this little piggy
boom comes off what did i tell you about
daddy's knuckle that's the first place
you cut off
all the time there you go
the next addition to our prawn salad is
firm juicy baby gem lettuce
look at the lettuce in half what about
the butt
the butts
[Music]
i'm keeping the butts on for now so when
i slice it it stays together okay and
then a little bit there
we don't use
okay
when you prepare lettuce for picnic you
never slice it too thinly
okay otherwise it will it's good prawns
already
[Music]
your tummy sauce is ready your dressing
is ready take the lid off
and the trick is
you dress
the bottom of your dish because i'm
going to put the prawns on here to
protect the lettuce
get your cucumber
i put my cucumber on
and then finally that is
okay
now the salad's not gonna go soft why is
that because it's not that it's not
straight onto the dressing that's right
what happens is we wrap this now and
then we get to our picnic drizzle the
sauce on top we mix it up we've got the
dressing on the bottom and the dressing
on top
of the dressing on top that's right
a little bit of tim film do you know the
cling film trick i don't know the clip
field trick yet no things fell over the
top of the toilet
what you don't understand it when you're
my age
oh you've been my age then well okay
salad in the fridge with the dressing
ready to go for a picnic
this is my ultimate picnic dinner feast
prawn and cucumber salad with a spicy
yogurt dressing
anchovy dip with crudites
and the kids favorite chocolate
marshmallow and peanut fridge cake